do you find yourself avoiding taking
risks it's pretty natural for us to want
to resist unpleasant emotions like
stress anxiety or unhappiness but this
fear can really hold us back so life is
really a jagged path and instead of
trying to meet every setback by trying
to force yourself forward and avoid
encountering those difficulties putting
things off procrastinating worrying
about what other people think allowing
anxiety in allowing the worry and unlock
just sitting comfortably next to
situations and things aren't quite going
to plan and keeping on going keeping on
towards that ultimate goal that for me
is the biggest difference between how I
used to think and how I think now
because it's so much more
psychologically liberating when you can
understand that things are going to
always go to plan and that's okay